nous sommes aujourd'hui sur le parvis du
centre europe dans le quartier europe
qui était un endroit important dans le
canton que j'ai l'honneur et le plaisir
de représenter au sein du département du
haut rhin le centre europe c'est un
endroit où se réunissent de nombreuses
personnes de nombreuses associations où
il se passe beaucoup d'activités
culturelles sportives sociales
c'est très important parce que le vivre
ensemble participe à cette bonhomie du
du quartier le fait que les habitants
puissent se retrouver puisse avoir des
activités puissent être soutenus
notamment par le département est un gage
de justement de vivre ensemble et le
vivre ensemble c'est quelque chose
auquel le département et auxquels je
suis particulièrement attaché alors le
centre europe se situe dans le quartier
europe qui a fait l'objet d'une
importante rénovation urbaine soutenus
dans le cadre de l'anru soutenu par le
par le département
on est parti du principe que les
logements c'est là où on passe le plus
de temps
il faut qu'il soit le plus digne
possible pour que les gens puissent
avoir une vie qui soit digne aussi et on
s'aperçoit d'ailleurs que et c'est une
plutôt une bonne nouvelle et un bon
message que ce qui est respectable et
respecté parce que le quartier même si
tout n'est jamais parfait est plutôt
dans un très bon état et peu de tags
pleut peu de dégradations et c'est
plutôt quelque chose qui nous satisfait
beaucoup la fa l'europe c'est aussi une
salle culturelle au sein du centre
europe et c'est une salle importante
parce qu'il se déroule énormément de
concerts il ya le festival de jazz
qu'est le département participe il ya
beaucoup de concerts puisque la culture
fait partie également des attributions
du département et sont soutenus par la
collectivité départementale
et ce qui est intéressant dans la salle
europe c'est que c'est une salle qui est
destiné bien sûr aux gens du quartier
europe mais qui va beaucoup au delà qui
va nettement au delà puisque tous les
colmariens yvon ce site est tout à leur
l'exemple du festival de jazz où chaque
année lors de ce festival des colmariens
de tous les quartiers
même au delà s'y retrouvent et c'est ce
que nous voulions faire aussi de cet
endroit là c'est à dire un lieu où se
soit pas simplement un lieu de quartier
mais un lieu qui résonne et qu'ils
soient destinés à l'ensemble de la vie
culturelle de la ville de colmar dans le
quartier europe il ya également le
collège molière qui est un collège très
important bien entendu gérer parce que
c'est un collège par le département
on a la chance d'avoir une équipe
pédagogique extrêmement dynamique et
positive et surtout et c'était un
engagement que j'avais pris avec ma
collègue martin dietrich lors de la
dernière campagne électorale des
départementales c'était de faire en
sorte qu'ils ne classe bilingue qui
ouvre au sein de ce collège et c'était
pas évident parce que l'état n'y était
pas dans un premier temps favorable mais
c'est un engagement important est aussi
un signal donné que le bilinguisme qui
est aussi quelque chose qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur parce que le
bilinguisme c'est l'apprentissage de la
langue du voisin
c'est un atout économique c'est
important aussi sur le plan culturel
parce que ce sont nos racines c'est
notre culture alsacienne et et rhénane
plus largement et bien le fait d'ouvrir
dans une zone urbaine sensible et dans
une
collège comme molière une classe
bilingue c'est aussi le signal fort et
j'y c'était parce que cette classe là à
ouverte cette année pour la première
fois que le bilinguisme concerne
l'ensemble des publics n'est pas réservé
à certains établissements c'est là
d'ailleurs un des premiers collèges
situés dans une zone comme celle là qui
a une classe bilingue en son sein nous
sommes sur le parking de l'ancien
supermarché match en plein coeur du
quartier europe qui est évidemment un
lieu important dans le canton que j'ai
le plaisir
de représenter au département du haut
rhin c'est vrai que mercredi c'est le
jour du marché et c'est un moment
important pour moi parce que je me rends
très régulièrement car je pars du
principe qu'un élu doit être au contact
de sa population tout au long de l'année
et pas uniquement comme c'est le cas
parfois malheureusement au moment des
périodes électorales
être au contact de la population pour
connaître les besoins les aspirations
les soucis de la population et faire
remonter et puis c'est de trouver des
solutions alors si j'ai souhaité
aujourd'hui être présent ici c'est parce
que on est à quelques pas de deux
magasins importants qui vont réouvrir le
magasin action qui a réouvert et qui
était un besoin d'un quartier et puis
l'ancien match qui va réouvrir dans
quelques semaines et qui sera normal et
c'est important parce que un quartier a
besoin de lieux de vie à deux depuis
deux lieux économique où il ya du monde
qui se retrouvent
nous sommes à quelques pas aussi de la
pépinière d'entreprises située rue du
luxembourg qui va bientôt rouvrir
également et qui est un enjeu majeur
pour les entreprises qui souhaitent se
crée qui souhaitent se développer qui
ont besoin d'avoir des locaux mis à la
disposition c'est un dispositif qui fait
partie du dispositif en rue et coeur de
ville et auquel bien entendu le
département participe également
financièrement
et puis à quelques pas d'ici nous sommes
au centre médico social de cms qui est
un bâtiment également départementale
avec des assistantes sociales qui
permettent aux gens du quartier mais
d'ailleurs au delà du quartier est bien
d'avoir des rendez-vous et de pouvoir
traiter des problèmes plus personnels
plus sociaux ça fait partie de la
solidarité c'est la dimension sociale
on est bien entendu au coeur des
compétences du département et de sa
quartier qui est bien sociologiquement a
besoin justement de tous ses soutiens et
le département est là au travers d'un
certain nombre de dispositifs mais
surtout au travers de moyens humains
parce que le social c'est à la fois la
proximité et c'est l'intérêt de la
collectivité départementale
mais c'est également et surtout l'humain
des humains qui viennent en aide à
d'autres humains je tenais être devant
le parc des expo de colmar pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que
évidemment c'est un lieu emblématique de
colmar mais qui rayonne au delà de
colmar sur l'ensemble du département et
même de la région d'ailleurs bien
entendu c'est le lieu de la foire aux
vins qui se déroule chaque année et
depuis deux ans d'ailleurs un cheval
entre le mois de juillet fin juillet et
le mois d'août
c'est un lieu voilà festif c'est la
foire aux vins et le vin fait partie à
la fois de nos paysages de notre adn de
notre culture et de notre force
économique ici à colmar capitale des
vins d'alsace mais dans tout le haut
rhin et
le soutien à la profession au profession
viticole vigneronne est important et
département joue un rôle en la matière
le parc des expositions de colmar c'est
aussi un centre important où
s'organisent de nombreux congrès avec
des grandes sagas avec la salle qui peut
contenir plus de 1200 places qui peut
être transformé le congrès c'est
important parce que et c'est là dans la
dimension du tourisme qui est une des
responsabilités importantes du
département
les congrès ça permet de faire rayonner
la ville ça permet de faire rayonner le
territoire pour attirer un maximum de
monde sur le plan du tourisme mais
également sur le plan économique et le
département est particulièrement attaché
au fait que ce centre de congrès puisse
vivre puisse se développer et nous y
prenons une part tout à fait importante
dans le dispositif et la question à ce
niveau-là de l'attractivité du
territoire et l'attractivité du
territoire le rayonnement du territoire
est une démission également bien entendu
de notre collectivité
nous sommes à quelques mètres de la zone
industrielle nord de colmar où on a la
chance d'avoir des fleurons important de
l'industrie entreprises timken
l'entreprise liebherr qui à elles deux
emploie plus de 1800 personnes c'est
tout à fait considérable plus les autres
entreprises du secteur
c'est très important bien entendu pour
le département parce que ce sont des
emplois parce que ce sont des personnes
qui travaillent
parce que c'est aussi au coeur de
l'attractivité de notre territoire et le
département est un facilitateur et doit
être un facilitateur pour permettre à
ces entreprises de continuer à exister
de continuer à se développer de
continuer à investir et au travers
notamment de la dira qu'ils jouent un
rôle important sur le plan économique
eh bien
nous mettons en relation des
investisseurs avec des services de
l'adira parce que être au coeur de ces
deux économies et être moteur dans ce
domaine là est quelque chose qui est
important pour nous département je
souhaitais au travers de ses différentes
cartes postales mettre en valeur les
forces du canton dans lequel je suis
issu en parlant de du social de la
solidarité de l'activité économique
en parlant de culture en parlant de
sport en parlant de la zone a dû ce
qu'elle est du parc des expositions
c'est pas exhaustif du canton mais femme
est bien valeur l'attractivité de notre
territoire et ce pour quoi je me bats au
sein du département depuis que je suis
élu défendre la population défendre les
intérêts de la population et défendre
l'attractivité du canton